[Applause]
emmanuel macron gambled that a short but
intense election campaign would be
enough
it was his comfortable margin of victory
over marine le pen gives him a second
term at the elysee palace only two
presidents before him have managed that
in his victory speech macron promised
that his next five-year term would be
different
this new era will not be a continuity of
the five previous years but the
collective invention of a revised method
for five better years for our country
and our youth
for his supporters this is a win that
endorses what they believe is their
country's role at the heart of the
european union
i'm very happy up to the last minute i
thought i would have fainted you never
know in life anything can happen
today abstentions were significant but
emmanuel macron did a good job in the
first years of his mandate and he
deserves to lead france again
marine le pen gave the far right their
highest share of the vote in a french
election but her path to the presidency
was blocked again by a republican front
in other words many voters who'd
supported other candidates in the first
round voted this time to keep le pen out
the game is not over since in three
weeks time we will have the legislative
elections
that as we know are a distortion of the
political trend and create a risk of
emanuel macron concentrating all
executive and legislative powers
john luke mellon sean the far left
presidential candidate took just one
percent less of the vote than le pen in
the first round he wants his party
france unbowed to win enough support in
the legislative elections that macron is
forced to appoint him prime minister
to all of you i say do not resign
yourself on the contrary go candidly and
completely into the action democracy can
once again give us the means to change
direction
the war in ukraine and the rising cost
of living were main concerns for french
voters both issues will likely dominate
the start of macron's second term
there probably won't be much of a grace
period for the president especially from
the left many of whom voted for him
reluctantly macron has promised to raise
the retirement age make it easier to
hire and fire workers and reform
unemployment benefits protests
asgardia's first term
could erupt again
bernie al jazeera